tras las protestas ciudadanas y de
grupos prodemocracia ahora es la rama
militar la que intensifica su oposición
a la reforma judicial del gobierno de
Benjamín netanyahu 37 de los 40
reservistas de uno de los principales
escuadrones de la fuerza aérea israelí
se niegan a entrenar este miércoles en
rechazo al polémico proyecto que temen
que socave la independencia judicial la
democracia y también la economía el
boicot de este escuadrón que ha
participado de operaciones como el
ataque a un reactor nuclear en Siria en
2007 es muy representativo porque Israel
primero depende de los reservistas para
reforzar su ejército regular y segundo
se supone que las fuerzas militares
deben ser imparciales y a políticas esa
idea ha quedado en entredicho Porque
estos pilotos son solo los últimos de
una lista cada vez mayor de críticos
dentro de las fuerzas israelíes ya se
sabía de otros reservistas y militares
que participan de las marchas pero ahora
la unidad cibernética del ejército y
otras decenas de reservistas están
revelando sus inquietudes en concreto
temen que si se aprueba la reforma A
falta de una Independencia judicial
dentro de Israel sean Entonces los
tribunales internacionales los que
juzguen al estamento militar en una
aparente respuesta Benjamín netanyahu
tuiteó una foto de cuando servían el
ejército con la leyenda cuando nos
llaman para el servicio de reserva
siempre nos presentamos y esto ocurre
ante otra sospecha de boicot por la
supuesta negativa de los pilotos de la
aerolínea local elal de trasladar a
netanyahu en su visita oficial a Italia
de este jueves horas después la compañía
señaló que habían encontrado al personal
y que la demora no fue por razones
políticas sino por una falta de
tripulación calificada